big announcement huge enormous maybe my
biggest ever announcement this thursday
the long awaited day the day when the
tickets for the dire ceo live show
which is with myself and my musical
entourage go on sale is this thursday at
10 a.m on thedirevaceolive.com
this thursday at 10 a.m set your
reminders put it in your calendar i hope
i get to see you in either london
glasgow newcastle or birmingham and i
hope i get to meet a ton of you we're
gonna have an amazing evening we're
gonna feel something together and
honestly that live show is the most
fulfilling rewarding thing i get to do
so i hope i hope i see you there 10 a.m
this thursday please get a ticket
me playing was
it was just a dream
growing up
it's a family 24 brothers and sister one
breast chicken was
for three days growing up in the street
you need to survive now when i have
those image in my head i could hear him
trying to touch me and touching himself
in the same time next to the bed you
know
i was even attaching my pajama with my
shoelaces
because to make sure like he can't put
it down and uh one day he did and i was
just like terrorized so that's the
things i grew up with like you know i
can't cry for me crying was a sign of
weakness
when i do a video and i see a comment
someone say oh patrice my dad passed
away i watch one of your video and i
smile
thank you
this is more important for me than win
the championship or the premier league
i'm not perfect and i don't want to be
perfect i want to be me
patrice evra
i've just sat here with him for an hour
and a half
and at the very end of the conversation
he said something which i think is the
perfect description
of the man
he referred to himself as an iceberg
i followed him for almost two decades
and he was to me this football icon this
tough guy this defender this champion
but as he says in this conversation
the part of the iceberg that i never got
to see
was the most compelling
was the most heartbreaking
and what's the most interesting
he grew up in a rough part of france
with 24 brothers and sisters
he was sexually abused by his head
teacher
his brother
a drug addict
overdosed and died
his mother raised him in total poverty
to the point where he stole his food his
shoes
and his entertainment
he endured
an early upbringing
that you would never wish on any child
an enemy or anyone at all
in any circumstances ever
and he hid it all
he hid it all for his entire life
and only recently
has he found it within himself
after very personal conversations with
his mother
to share it with the world
and only today
on this podcast
has he decided to share some of those
heartbreaking details
after watching him on tv for
almost two decades
i thought i knew patrice evra this
comedian
football champion funny guy happy guy
i was wrong
all i knew was the tip of the iceberg
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
i've sat here with a lot of guests
and sometimes i feel obliged to start
with their childhoods because it seems
like the the foundation of most people
specifically successful people tends to
be the case that the things they go
through an early age
especially with my sort of little
background in childhood psychology tend
to shape them the most but when i read
your story in your book
that's just come out
um having watched you on screen as a
manchester united fan for many many a
decade and seen
subsequently the guy you were on
instagram the hilarious entertaining
person i never ever would have guessed
ever
that that was your upbringing that was
your childhood i would have guessed by
the person that i came to know on screen
by the person that i watched on
instagram i would have guessed the
opposite
take me back so before you were 10 years
old because i know that 10 years old was
a really pivotal moment in your life
because your father left yeah what was
life like before
it was
an happy happy child a lot of people
inside the house sometimes you have to
make sure like you're ready when mom
said the food is ready
it was like sleeping with two of my
siblings in the same bed a single bed
and you know two was sleeping that way
and one on that way sometimes it was
like some smelly fit but
we need space and it was all about like
sharing but i will tell you something i
was happy
you know even if i was like begging in
front of shop you know to buy a sandwich
i couldn't say in that time i wasn't
happy i was like the most happy child
but it was like tough and
maybe sometime i was just saying
conscious
but
of course i think
when my dad left
that's when i was like okay i'm not
scared of anyone in this house so now i
have to grow up on my own and that's
when i was like i would say more close
to the street because when my dad was
here you know just when i was saying
like that i want to go and play outside
with my friend he was like did you have
you done your homework
even i swear even if i did my homework i
was scared to say yes so when you say
yes to him he was like okay bring me
your
your book
and i remember it was like okay which
lesson you have to learn tomorrow and i
was like doing the lesson perfectly and
he was going to the first page of the
book
and saying like okay tell me about this
and i couldn't remember i was like yeah
but that we did this at the beginning
you know
this is like
okay when you learn your full book then
you will be able to go outside
so
my dad when he was at home we didn't
miss anything
you know we have food on the table
everything was perfect i had like a big
screen tv i remember we are one of the
first family in where i grew up in my
street to have that big screen and all
my friends they come so
i i i couldn't i would never complain
when my dad was here he did his job
perfectly but
the only things you know
my dad uh
teach me
uh crying is a weakness
so when he was like
punishing someone and you cry that's
when you're gonna you're gonna beat you
even more
so that's the things i grew up with like
you know i can't cry and that's why we
can talk about that toxic masculinity
they understand crying is normal but for
me crying was a sign of weakness
why did he leave
he lived because my mom divorced him
and sometimes he was uh
it was violent
with her and i remember
you know being kids and no one asked me
these questions that's why i'm a little
bit
emotional and
and you know my mom was like
no
one man can
raise his hand on me
so
she divorced
he had to leave you know she went to the
police and uh
and he had to go and it was a tough
moment because you know when you see
your dad leaving no matter if you know
the reason he shouldn't have done that
uh
leave
the same taking all the sofa the the big
tv the big screen
he was with a big trunk waiting for him
and we were all off my brother and
sister crying because you know it's your
dad
but
at the same time what he was doing to my
mom he wasn't right
so did you witness that
yeah i think like
you know sometimes we try to open the
door and uh
if you open that door
you know
it was uh it was really scary you know
and if you when you heard your mom like
fighting back because to be fair my mom
she's a strong woman you know and my dad
say that now we say like
don't play with your mom because she's a
strong woman so
in in that time yeah
when you experience that you
you just terrorize you like what's
what's going on you know it's your
parents they should like kiss each other
so yeah
and you look back on that moment he left
obviously incredibly sad moment but are
you happy that he left
considering
the problem you know when you kid you
you don't really understand
i was happy because my mom
at the end you know she was uh
she was happy
but to see that left
leaving no matter which reason you can't
be happy
now i understand the reason
uh i forgive him
but uh saying i was happy no
so he leaves
your life takes a turn after that
because
you've lost that figure in your life and
maybe a bit of
i don't know restriction has left the
family home so
you can act on other motivations and
incentives and other ways to survive i
guess
and what what's the what person did you
become after that
i was a while
like a warrior yeah
i think a survivor
because after like i say you know it's
you in the street
and
[Music]
oh oh i kill you or you kill me
you know when you grow up in the street
that's why i hate when some people they
talk about their background and they'll
say like
oh i was a gangster no
i would never call myself a gangster i
was just a survivor
and it was difficult you know
so yeah like you said when he left
no more restriction
going out
fighting outside
lying to your mom
uh the police you know
bring me one day home
around 1 00 am
my mom was so worried like
and i remember it was so funny because
some words i didn't even know what they
mean
so
when they bring me back home and my mom
was you know just she put her
like a hand on her mouth what's going on
she was you know
his son you know bring back from the
police and
i was like my mommy are just being an
accomplice
and she bit me like so bad
but now i understand is even worse you
know because i was like i didn't steal i
just was looking when my friend was
stealing and stuff like that
so it was just a mess and
no one
even my school teacher when they were
talking to me at school i was like can
you put the volume down you're not my
dad
so i didn't let anyone you know talking
like
saying you can't do this you can't do
that but i always respect my mom
uh and my brother and my sister
and i was a
i was respectful with my friend but when
someone tried to give me some authority
he couldn't have it because i was like
the one i have like the most authority
on me it was my dad he left
so now
i don't need any authority from now on
and you get you start
i read you started stealing things yeah
you started selling weed yeah i think
stealing was uh was normal because i was
like with my friend i remember the first
time i i still it was a
some gum
and you know i was hungry up with my
friend they were stealing i wasn't
because i was still like having a good
education for my dad for my mom
and to be part of the group you need to
you know it's like some people when they
drink because they they find that excuse
to be like social
so it was stealing so i started still
and everyone clapped me
so i was like wow finally i'm part of
the gun
and from there you go like to deal like
video games
uh to sell weed you know to having the
best like sneakers and you know even
offering some stuff to your girlfriend
i offer even like a perfume to my mom
you know and i was so proud because i
was like at the end you know my dad left
a few of my brother's sister left after
that also so
i was like i'm the man
i need to be in charge i need to feed my
family
it wasn't the right way every time
but at least i was like
you know my mom like when i offer him
like a bottle of bathroom and i see how
happy she was but she was like always
where'd that come from and i was like
lying you know it's just my friend you
know he
he bought it for me but i was me he was
myself stealing it
some years after your father left you
did you talk about in the book and the
opening chapters of the book
about your headmaster
yeah and you were 13 years old you
um
you ended up staying at his house
and he sexually assaulted you
yeah
i think
this is what's
one of the
most regret i had in my life to not
speak up in that day
um
how did you come to be at his house
it's really simple it's because
uh
bretty it was far from my house i have
to take two trains to go to school
because i went to that school because it
was a school where
you know you're good at football you
after school you have to train so it
wasn't an academy but it was a school
where you can train also so it was a
good opportunity to be fair my mom was
like he's good he's leaving the street
because he will end up in jail or dead
so it's perfect for him so i
i went there and i was taking like you
know two train four hours sometime and
uh losing my uh my school bag sleeping
on the train you know even sometimes end
up like to another destination so it was
a mess and uh that school teacher ed's
teacher
he speak to me said you won't like to
stay because i live i'm living inside
the
school you have his home inside the
school
so i went back home and i say to my mom
you know he offered that and
my mom was like not sure about it at the
beginning because even when i tell her i
would speak letter about it she she i
knew it and she was like are you sure
can you trust this man i was like yay he
seemed nice mom
so
that ed teacher at the beginning
everything was perfect
he was uh cooking for me in the evening
he was letting me play as nintendo he
had the nintendo at the time so i was
like yeah that's that's cool you know i
don't need to go back home on the
weekend and
i just stay here and
[Music]
then
every night
i was in my bed and uh
every time he was coming you know in my
room and i was the first time i was like
maybe you know just say come to say good
night
but he was uh i was sleeping and i was
feeling a hand on my body and i was like
oh what's going on you know
then he was trying to touch me but i was
like holding his end
so it was like a fight for for 10
minutes
and i was still
couldn't understand i was 13 but you
know
i i didn't have any uh
sexual relation even with any girls at
that time so for me was everything was
new i was like what's what's going on
you know
um
we fight many times
and he didn't succeed
and he was you know now when i have
those image in my head i could hear him
trying to touch me and touching himself
in the same time next to the bed you
know
then he was living and every time i was
like oh it's gone so he's start to
become a ritual
every time i go to bed
he's coming
the same things fight everything fight
fight
and uh
one day
you know i was even attaching my pajama
with my late laces like i remember yeah
shoelaces
because to make sure like he can't put
it down and uh
we felt you know he was trying like on
the top of my clothes but fighting said
so one day he did he put my pants down
and he put my penis in his mouth
and
i was just like terrorized i remember i
was i just freeze
you know i knock his head but i and i i
just freeze i couldn't
i didn't understand what's going on
then he left
then i woke up i can't even remember
what's happened because
you know those things you just like
erase them from your memory
so i back
to school
i think in school i was thinking about
what's what happened it's like something
not normal then
then i went home i said mom i don't want
to sleep anymore to that ed teacher
she said why i said no i just don't want
i never tell her the reason
until now
so
after that i live
all my life with that
from the street you know you come back
you're like imagine you tell that to one
of your friends
they're gonna say you know
you're weak
i lost their stuff
so
[Music]
even for me when i had my first sexual
relation
it was weird because i had this man in
my head
you know and this i never told that to
anyone
so i was like massively traumatized
actually because all of that i back to
my school where i grew up in the street
and i stopped even going to that school
even like people were like but you're so
good at football why i said i don't need
it i will keep training on my own on the
street you know i don't want to be in
that school anymore
so
yeah i grew up with that things for so
many years
and what i feel as a cohort is when i
was 24 years old not 20 years old
and i was still playing for monaco at
the time
and the police called me
so i miss uh this is the number of
patricia yeah um you know we got a lot
of complain about that a teacher i don't
even remember his name i don't i could
even tell you his face because i erased
all of this in my memory
uh
it's been a lot of complain about child
they're being abused about that teacher
did he touch you
no
are you sure
yes i'm sure
and i was angry even when people asked
me that question you know i was like oh
there someone asked me about that
put the phone down
so all this year i was like wow patrice
you had the opportunity when you were 13
years old you didn't i will understand
but now you're 20
and you couldn't just what because you
still shame of it
because you're famous
you're scared of the reaction of the
people
but doing that
that day
that's why growing up
when people say patrice you're good guys
i wasn't feeling that that way because i
was feeling as a coward
a coward a coward yeah because he wasn't
about
patrice
it was about the other child i let down
when the police call me it's about or
the child is still being abused right
now
so coming out with this
helped me a lot
and i have to say a massive thanks to
the woman of my life margot because
you know sometimes people say you need a
psychology but in life sometimes it's
about which person you meet i'm someone
i really believe in energy and to be
fair after that trusting anyone of
psychology
i would say maybe i would tell him this
he don't care it's just pay for that job
some of them are really good i never i
never met any cycle about
me that woman like
she was a romantic partner yeah
she she
she make me
being myself and being honest with
myself
don't be ashamed of anything baby and
i'm here
and i will never
me but raise the tough guys
don't showing emotion
think a woman can you know extract those
real emotions from myself
i was like wow
13 years old there was a day you told
you shared that with her yeah can you
tell me about that dave
like i say the day i share that with her
it was uh
you know when she met me
i was 38 so i was just
retired from football
doing all my things and
oh my god you
you seem so happy
and such a positive man
but i do you care about yourself
fortress
i said yeah
and she asked me one simple question
are you happy
yes i'm happy i'm happy you know
i make you happy i make my
patrice what make you
happy uh
i'm happy
no i'm
just saying like i'm happy this is not
an answer so she go deep
and we didn't talk about the subject i
say no i'm fine she said no because i
can see yes you're an impulsive person
you like to fight you say because this
from the street and everything but i
think you got something you got a pain
on your chest and you don't want i was
like i'm fine
i'm fine
then one day
we watched something and it was about
pedophile and stuff so
[Music]
again she looked at my face she said
like you okay
i said yeah i'm okay why you asked me no
but tris
i feel you
you're hiding something
i say why why you you know i don't like
when people want to try
inside go to get inside i'm fine i was
still closing the door
if you love me you should like tell me
what's going on i need to i need to know
already
i look at her i just try crying like a
baby
i cry like a baby she hugged me
what's going on
and i tell her the full story
so she cried
she was like i knew
thank you if you say that to someone to
the police to your mom i said no
you are the first person and i don't
want to say to anybody else
do you want to see a
do you go for do you want to go for
therapy and i said i'm fine i told you
no patrice
you're gonna explode one day
you need to you know let it out
then when i cry and uh
i feel much better about myself
and i was still like
you know i cry in front of her now she
will take advantage of me
she'll think i'm weak
but she was like you know baby
i even love you more this is a strain
stop thinking this is a weakness
that's when she introduced me
to that toxic masculinity couldn't
understand before
she explained me what it was about
like being a man is not like being
strong or
i was like this is my education this is
the way i grow up this is why the dad
like many died they do the same mistake
and i did the same with my first child
lenny
sometimes he was talking to me i was
like you got everything why you complain
come on ah daddy you know when i was
doing this come on don't be awake
that you know he's painful ah it's okay
but when i think about all of that now
i'm like
because i live with that toxic
masculinity
and i think men
like us
have to change that
crying
is a strain
and you know when you grow in the
streets just like holding the hand of
your girlfriend is a sign of weakness
you're not allowed to do that
so
i'm discovering myself
we're gonna believe that i'm 38 years
old now i'm 40 i will start to discover
myself
now everything makes sense
that trauma make me
become who i am like sometimes a soldier
like no emotion i'm going to do the job
sometime i win some trophy we celebrate
it was fake
i didn't i wasn't like that happy
if you ask me patrice
are you happy now i say yes
now i'm complete i'm content i feel
blessed and i feel lucky but when i used
to play football
i was a robot i was just doing my job
your brother
you talked about the fact that you
started dealing drugs back when you were
younger and then your your brother
started taking drugs
yeah
this was a
another massive trauma you know
when you wake up
in the
in the morning and you just want to go
in the toilet
and you open the door and you see your
your browser with uh you know
uh and uh oh you said a needle a needle
yeah
and looking at you with like eyes you
know like
red eyes and
just closing the door
and you have to hold on your
you know if you want to pee you have to
hold it because it's there and it was
one toilet in the whole house so
and this teach me
to never
touch any drug because i saw my brother
and he lost his life because of that he
lost his life he died as overdose in
senegal he even sell his uh his document
his french passport
and he went in senegal and one day they
called my mom my auntie said your son is
dead
in a bathroom
so it was tough for me to talk about
this in my book because
my mom
she's the son of my mom
and i don't have the right to talk about
it in my book
because we're talking about a dead
person
but i just
unfortunately
this show me like taking drugs i can
lose my life
like the same for alcohol
[Music]
i didn't drink until i was 33 years old
because for me the glass of i call it
was the homeless people living in my
street and anyway my mom and my dad
don't drink
so i never had that culture so that's
why i couldn't understand when i came in
england
and people were drinking even like
footballer players and you know when we
were going to party they were always
saying to the waitress can we have a hot
chocolate for patrice
because
the alcohol and the drugs it was like
you're gonna end up dead
poison
you know
um
so going back to this topic of toxic
masculinity it's something i've actually
been thinking a lot about because my
girlfriend funnily enough has started to
talk to me a lot about the idea this is
why i was just remaining quiet and
listening first but but um she started
talking to me a lot about the idea of
the masculine and the feminine and how
a rounded healthy man embodies both
sides of him and is able to tap into
both sides of him sounds like your early
years
um
made you use one of those sides which is
the masculine side as a form of
self-defense in many ways as a way to
survive
because i'm hearing what you went
through and i'm thinking
the you know using the feminine energy
the the emotion the expression of you
know ones how someone feels care the
softness
wouldn't have been conducive with
survival in that situation so as you get
40 years on how do you then unlearn your
survival technique
how do you how do you unlearn the the
masculine defensive don't cry don't show
weakness which you now know is
is um important for you to have good
relationships
romantic relationships to be balanced
yourself to be open to be expressive and
to not self-destruct
what i love about you is the way you
question myself you even make me think
but you're right
if i have this
feminine you know emotion in that time
i won't survive
because we know women are more emotional
than men
so what you just said to me i'm like
yeah patrice
you want to fight against that uh
toxic masculinity but you're happy when
you need it now because you're 40 years
old you don't need it anymore and you're
a dad now so you're gonna teach
you're gonna teach but i'll be honest
with you that's why
you know
my woman was scared when we have our son
uh
she was like patrice
before he evolved i don't want him to be
like you
wow
she put that on my face
what do you mean
yeah i want him to be
determined passion
funny positive but i don't want him to
have your emotion
back off yeah i was like but i think you
know when he cried i would say like
don't don't cry she was that's exactly
what i'm talking about
when you cry i want you to say it's okay
let your emotion out
but it's difficult for me at the
beginning so i was like
nah
i want i don't want him to cry when he
fall and everything
the funny part
is
when she was still pregnant
uh you know one woman this is more about
relationship because now i know
relationship is not just about love it's
about caring and communication
you know i don't want to be like now the
priest or because when i talk like
there's so many people like that oh i
wish my husband is like you know
i've been the bad guys too
so don't get me wrong
but
now i'm more like
feeling
like
so back to that moment
we were in the car
she was with a drink and i said don't
drink because he's bumpy and you're
gonna and she hate like you know having
mark on her she drink but
fall on the shirt yesterday on the show
she cry
i promise you steve
i
cry instantly with her because
i feel her
i feel a a sadness
the whole patrice will be like come on
why are you crying just because you
speak common
but in that moment i didn't
i wasn't focused on the the reason why
she's crying i was like just on the
emotion she's crying
she's in pain
you don't need to fix it
she need a hug
the moment she saw me crying she stopped
crying
she stopped crying straight away
and for me it was new i was like what's
going on
i can't even feel your pain you know
sometimes you say you love someone
but this is like a deep love like even
now she cry i cry automatically even now
we're talking when she's next to me i
miss her
i never experienced that
and now he's so special so to come back
to my son
when he cry now
you know my woman can be oh come on
leela ah
i'm like but it's okay
you know it must be a reason it's
because he's angry so
i'm the one softer now
so that's what i'm like wow
you're just a different man we had a
rule
if we argue because don't get me wrong
we argue like normal couple we're not
special
but it's just like we don't put it under
the carpet
we fix it
but not like we force it in a natural
way
when for example we argue straight away
and she said we need to talk because
women say we need to talk i'm not ready
we need to talk i'm not no give me my
space
then i come back okay
let's talk about it
i'm apologize but i'm apologize because
i mean it
not because you forced me to apologize
and you're not trying to win i'm not
trying to win
and then i understand i'm like okay baby
how lucky we are
the special love we have right now like
i will never believe the way i believe
in love right now that's why i'm
encouraging
all the kids the next generation
this love exists
but
it exists so the it's again you you it
sounds like you're just recounting my
life specifically over i met i met a
lady she's called uh
i would say melanie
uh she she was very keen on she said
very similar things to me she was like
there's something you've not told me
about et cetera and her real sort of
drive with me has been trying to make me
tap into the feminine side of me which
again means opening up being vulnerable
removing my ego when we argue it's to
try and solve a problem as opposed to
trying to win and that also and she
slowly got this different person out of
me in my previous relationship snapping
wow leave i'll just leave right yeah and
in this one it's like she lets me speak
i let her speak okay sometimes we but
we're both trying to understand the
person and the thing that really changed
it's funny because when you talked about
that day when you opened up with your
partner about what had gone on she
created a safe space
and once you have that safe space and
you learn that this is a safe space this
relationship is a safe space
you don't have to be that person you are
in the streets right you don't even have
to be the person you are on the group
chat on whatsapp you can cry you can say
babe i i feel insecure i feel triggered
and that for me has been this like
tremendous catalyst in myself because
now i can really investigate myself with
someone
right and know that they're not gonna
laugh at me or think i'm not a man yeah
because i'm crying or because i'm i've
got feelings right and that that meant
that again when you just described the
way you feel about her the sense like
when she's not by your side you didn't
know a love like this existed i was
saying that this morning i've just left
her in indonesia and i was saying i
didn't realize i could have a
relationship like this with someone
where every argument we have
heals our relationship to a stronger
place
it doesn't leave a scratch or a scar
which
that's the thing you know but
you you resume it perfectly and like you
say sometimes when we have a discussion
like
we all love even get even more stronger
stronger because we are in love with
each other but what i like what you say
a word safe yeah safe space it's a safe
space feeling safe yeah
allow to be yourself i'll say that to my
girlfriend now so i say this sounds like
i've never said this before but i'll
literally say to her i need a safe space
and that means that i'm about to say
some things which might trigger you
might make you unhappy but i need to say
it because it's how i feel so i'll
literally say give me a safe space yeah
and that means listen to me but it but
exactly you know i think is
it it's easy to to listen to someone but
to understand the person you know to
saying i heard you
this is different yeah you mean you
really understand because you can talk
for many hours i'm like yeah i'm
listening yeah you're not you're waiting
to speak
you're building your your argument
against no but but exactly but what you
say i think we're really similar and
i i was excited to come today and i'm
even more happy to be here and to keep
like talking we can talk i think many
hours and i just feel like so open even
talking about you you asked me a few
questions
about why my dad lived many things like
it was not easy to not cry no
i like that but this is something this
is something that men need to hear and
you think about just from what we've
both learned from our stories there with
relationships but just even two men
having a conversation like this
how how freeing that is for us how it's
healing for us but also it allows us to
form relationships which are real and
deep and meaningful where we don't want
to be running out in the street and so i
it's you know it's one of the real
things i think is going to form a big
part of
my life too as you've successfully done
with this book is trying to tell men
without having to meet the women like we
met
how to be in touch with their
the true i don't even say the feminine
side
the the full version of themself
i absolutely i think i i no but i i
absolutely agree with you because it's a
challenge because we have a little help
because we find someone like you say we
feel open and we can you know you can be
yourself
but yeah i think we we should fight with
that toxic masculinity because
it's not good even for yourself but even
for your
children for many for many reasons
but
you test me by saying patrice if you
didn't have that masculine you know
masculinity toxic masculinity how you
will be able to survive in that when you
were that kid
and i will be look at you straight away
and saying no
so
it's a good subject and i hope if you
want to
debate more about it
i will be a good client
either way we have to unlearn it right
we have to underline it once we realize
that it's not serving us and that is
admittedly a very slow process
one that goes
you know because even i
some i have to be very aware of that
part of me the masculine ego part of me
and i always think with trauma and with
these kinds of things you never actually
fully recover
i i think the most important thing is to
put out in front of you so that it's no
longer controlling your life from the
back room and ruining your relationships
and stuff just for me like i've got a
lot of traumas from my childhood with my
parents and what their relationship i
still have them and
i just have them out in front of me and
the power they have over me is
diminished i know what the triggers are
i know i understand them and i just want
to keep them out in front of me so i can
hopefully live a happy life
quick one
it's now the fourth quarter of the year
we're coming into the winter months here
in the uk november december january
these are always according to my apple
watch the months where my diet and my
fitness
fall off every single year and for me
that means i tend to resort to junk food
and i tend to stop going to the gym and
working out and this is why for me in
the fourth quarter
hewell is now my savior
i really really really mean that if
you're the type of person that can
resonate what i've just said and tends
to fall off with your diet and your
fitness in the fourth quarter one thing
i suggest you do is order a huge
subscription get it in your fridge
because for me if it's there i'll drink
it if it's not i'll probably have a
pizza at 4am in the morning and fries
and a burger and
an oreo milkshake so
having it in my home makes health
convenience so order your heel
subscription join me on this journey i'm
announcing something soon actually for
people that want to get in shape in the
new year i'm super excited to talk to
you about that and um
cure your diet avoiding junk food being
healthy vitamins minerals proteins
and no crap is going to be a big part of
that
and for me that's that's why huell is in
my life
football
bit of a segue
um
you're very good at football
i'm trying to figure out what like how
you became so good at football with all
of that stuff happening in your life and
that culture you're in and what football
was for you as a young man i have
everything
so football saved my life
when my friend they were stealing to get
away from the stealing i was like
training on my own even when it was
snowing but come on patrice you're never
going to to succeed anywhere you from
the street you you're uh you're a black
person you will never gonna make it you
know just find a white girlfriend with a
lot of money that's what's the the way
the people yeah i think in my street
stop you know you look cute you can just
find a girl and you know i was like no
you know i love football and i need to
training every day i remember even at
school
sometime when the we went to school and
the teacher couldn't make it because of
the traffic or the snow and
they were like okay we're free some kids
they wanted to go back home i was like
no no it's a football pitch just next to
the school we have to play and i was
threatening them sometimes they couldn't
like some kid i was like if you don't
come i'm gonna beat you
and they were coming and training yeah i
was forcing people to play football with
me why
it's an addiction i don't know it was my
reason of living is it your escape
i think i could say it was both it was
my escape but it was also my love my
passion
just when you gave me like a football
ball he was like everything for me you
know i remember that a teacher
the first day you you come at school and
they ask what you want to become later
and many people were lawyers uh
policeman
many good job doctor and
and me she was looking right um reading
what i was my note and footballer player
but i didn't even know what was
footballer player i was like i play
football but so a footballer player
and she was taking my note in front of
everyone and she was like
patrice
think footballer player is a job and
everyone was laughing everyone my friend
i was looking so
and she was going even deeper she was uh
but you know if he's a trial and 300 kid
they will pick one kid
do you think he's going to be
you i was like yes
and everyone was even more laughing
but at the end now i don't want to get
any revenge with that
teacher
i just want to make sure she don't say
the same things to other kids
because me in that time
i was really strong mentally
so no one you know can project their own
fear because some people i hate those
people once i'm going to this no you
can't because they try to projecting
their own failure on you me now if the
kids i was you know
i see some some some kid at the school
in manchester and i was like if you want
to become the president of the universe
go for it you're going to have a lot of
enemies and make a lot of sacrifices
there's no president of the universe i
know it doesn't exist that's what i mean
but that's what i mean i'm like the even
though like the job doesn't exist go for
it go for it
if you dream about it and that's
that's what's the beauty of me when i
was child like everyone like i did a
trial at psg
and
i did everything perfect at the end you
say
you're too small
and you're from the street and we scare
you're going to steal things in the
dressing room yeah that's right
psg that's what the coach told me
and they didn't take me just for those
two reasons
so
so i have a lot of like you won't make
it and more people do that more i'm like
that's why i say i'm lucky mentally i
can't tell you why i'm that strong maybe
about from my dad my mom or all the
things that i have to survive but this
was even making me more stronger did you
have a plan b
no
i didn't have any
plan b this was
all or nothing
and that's the scary things when i think
about it now because some of my friends
or some people they were like patrice
you know school is important you should
have your diploma and stuff
i was like i want to be a footballer
player but i get in shock
when i knew actually playing football
you can win money
i wasn't aware about that like when i
signed my first contract when i was 17
i didn't care about the money in that
time it will make you laugh you know
what i was most happy is when i saw my
track suit on the
on the bed and i wear it and i was
looking myself in the mirror and i was
oh my god and i went downstairs to join
the team and i see all the players
sitting the table and people coming to
serving them the food he was like
remember like three folk on one side
three knife on what side
i call my mom
i say mom
[Music]
i'm even like this is paradise
people serving us the food i've got like
tree now i've got a track suit we all
dressed the same and my mum cried at the
phone i remember that day
so
you know when people ask me what is your
best memory when you play football
that was my best memory
not winning the champions league or
this is when i was 17
you know that kid and
just
just having food
and a normal track suit
make me so happy
and that's my best memory i had
since i played football
because you'd made it
i made it that day
i was like i made it mama
i won't be in the street anymore i won't
have to survive to fight
i won't have to beg money
so it was just crazy and even in that
time even some people they still take
advantage
because when i signed my first contract
actually
i signed a paper with the mafia the
italian mafia and i was their
property
and i didn't doubt i found out this when
after i wanted to move for is homer
and is roma we say we have to call off
the deal because
you're the property of that man
and he was a guy he's from the mafia and
actually on that time i remember when i
first my my first contract
i was earning uh it was like 50 pound
now per month
and we had like five months
where they didn't pay us
uh
i remember my mom and my brother they
come to visit me in sicily and
you know a breast chicken
one breast chicken was
for three days we had to cut it like in
cube little cube
i remember she was like twisting in a
little bag
and that's it that was for the meal for
some time we had only one meal per day
but i was happy and i remember my mom
come to visit me in sicily
and she cried she said but what you
doing here
you know i was like
mommy i just love football she was like
but you have nothing
look where you live i was you know it
was like if you see my first flight i
mean like they allowed me to live on
that flat it was disaster but i was
happy because i had football and every
time
when i was training or when we played
the game
i was scared to the referee to to blow
the final whistle
because i was like what i'm going to do
now
i'm back to the reality
so for me playing was
it was just a dream
hard to imagine it's hard to
how to imagine how
how difficult life must be for you to
not want the whistle to blow on a
on a football game is
was there a moment where
where that changed and where you no
longer started to dread the final
whistle blowing because your life off
the pitch was
somewhere to look forward to
it is when i uh
i get rid of those people around me and
the the mafia and i i signed with a new
agent and
i signed for nice so i go back to france
a bigger salary
i think i was uh
earning something like uh 3k per month
so much better life be able to even help
my mom
and
from that moment i was like okay now
i'm safe
i'm safe and after you know i signed for
monaco of course
and i keep my word i say
you know when my dad left and in school
they gave you like a little money and my
dad was taking this money to send it to
senegal to my older brother and sister
so
i remember my sister
went after my mom like you know with
true lawyers and everything she get that
money from the school and not my dad
anymore
my sister get that money and she go to
buy like some makeup and everything i
was like shame on you
oh man like she's feeding us every
single day
like and why you don't give that money
and i i said me mommy i don't want
anything
this is for you
because you are living in your roof
you're feeding us every day this is for
no but patrice this is for you mommy i
don't need this and i say mom
when i'm gonna have my big contract the
first things i'm gonna do because that's
what's my motivation is to buy a house
to my mom
and i did it and i think that was one of
the most pride moment of my life because
i say to my mom and i keep my word and i
bought her a house in senegal before i
bought of course
with my money when i play for monaco my
porsche and everything cars because i
like cars
not now anymore because i understand how
stupid it is
but yeah that was uh
one of my biggest achievements because
she must have been proud right
my mom uh
my mom cry every time she see me
because uh
sometimes she's like you don't unders
many things you don't know patrice
like when you were like alone and
no one wanted to help us
and now that's why it's so funny when
suddenly you are someone and people they
like your auntie come back or your ankle
but they weren't there when you know we
need them the most so she always cries
she said i'm too nice but me i'm like i
don't have any hate in my heart it's
difficult
and uh manchester united
i'm uh
yeah
i
can't can't imagine what that would have
been like getting a getting a call that
that's uh but you will laugh because
before united i was that being of i will
call it overconfident and arrogant
i was playing for monaco i reached the
final of champions league
being named four time in the world the
best left back in the french league
playing for the national team
so i remember my agent came and he said
patrice you know in january he says
like teams like
inter liverpool manchester united
i say yeah
cool
i say and
what
stuck in my head when you say manchester
united cantona
really yeah
cantona you know yeah yeah the colors
yeah
wow i said okay man should say i swear
cantona yeah because i wasn't following
really yeah i can tell you something i i
don't watch football
you're supposed to say it was a
childhood dream yeah
it was just like it's just me i'm
playing football so watching football is
like going to work that's when i was
young but now as a pundit i have to
watch football game but it's something
i've never been interested in it's
something i never enjoyed so i didn't
know although sometimes i was watching
some results manchester united because
of cantona so
i say to me yeah okay he said you should
go to manchester i think manchester
should you say why not
then
we met uh sir alex ferguson because at
that time you know i still playing for
monaco so you can't be approached by
another team you know you broke the
rules
so
we met uh
in the airport
in a separate room yeah
a secret
yeah
and
that day that interview was like being
interviewed by the fbi
it was like do you smoke
do you drink do you like to party
are you ready to not lose one game are
you ready to not even draw a game
yes
sir alex yeah he shake my hands he said
now you shake my hands
so that's you know playing for my united
or everything i say that's what you you
will have to do and all the stuff even
if some people they drink and they do
many things but it was about more the
winning mentality
and when he shake mine he looked
straight in my eyes
and when you look straight at his eyes
you make sure you don't disappoint him
so
what i love about ferguson is that they
also say you know son we know your
background you know where you come from
but just be yourself i won't change you
i just want you to bleed for united for
the fun
for the people for manchester you know
uh
work ethic
and it was already in my dna so when i
joined united i was like
finally i can be myself because even in
france playing for monaco when sometime
i was saying like
i want to be the best left back oh i am
the best oh he's too arrogant is this so
the french media they didn't understand
me
they were like you know it's two hours
and i win also the the youngest french
player in the league and normally only
striker like angry zidane i was the
first defender to win those kind of
trophies so i was like overconfident
so
when i joined manchester and ferguson
tell me all those words it was a
different story
i was like finally i can express myself
like cantona say
you know in
france they will build him the
guillotine in manchester they will build
him a statue
and that's the truth because in
manchester they let you be yourself you
know even if you know you have to kick a
fan or stuff they will still be behind
they know is wrong
but you still feel the support you still
feel you're part of the family so we're
gonna accept you
you know
uh
the way you are
and that's what's really important even
if i think everyone knew the story
of my first game i think i said well
yeah
uh
just crazy because i i just
came back
i just trained with the team three days
we are the derby against manchester city
playing at 12
i never played 12 in my life apart when
i was kid but
never play at 12.
come for the breakfast
nine
i see mikhail silvestro luisa of my my
french teammate eating beans
you know pasta i'm not a good breakfast
guy so i start doing the same you know
i'm like okay in this league you know we
need to to eat because he's a strong
league i eat i feel sick
i went in my room i vomit
i said i need to call the doc and you
need to say to the manager i can't play
that game but i was like patrice you
just sign
you can't say that again toxic
masculinity they will say i'm weak i'm
scared
i play i say i play
don't ask me why you know
in manchester it's never sunny in nine
years i just done like three barbecue in
nine years
that day was so hot the sun was like on
my i was like dude i'm back to monte
carlo i was like what's going on here
i remember the first
the first bowl trevor sinclair just
headbutted me i was cut straight away he
was like welcome to england welcome to
the premier league and in one point one
point i was again the post i remember
you know when you have those bubble the
cartoon and you you know writing what
you think about
i was like oh my god what the hell i'm
doing here the football is so fast so
strong i should have kept chilling in
monte carlo
[Music]
losing to nil half time ferguson gave
the air dryer to everyone and he come to
me say you now you sit and you learn the
english football so i didn't understand
because you know i didn't speak very
well english and
carlos carius was the one like
translating and i put my you know the
doctor was like cleaning my blood and
and i put my and carlos girl said no no
patrice is it's over it's finished like
you serve
so imagine me playing for france best
left back
being served after the first 45 minutes
but he get even worse and worse after
that
so we lost the game i back home
and my italian agent with his wife were
staying with me in my flat
and my agent looked at me like this
he said patrice i'm sorry
say what
he said should never broke you in
manchester
i'm sorry you should have stayed in
monaco you know and his wife on the
background looking at me
i promise to say that that day
i was so low i was like even my own
agent he don't believe in me anymore i
was like wow
so after that i know i play a liverpool
game a good game we win 1-0 rio
ferdinand scored the winning goal and
everything and i had a great game so he
back but the first six months was really
difficult for me and nemanja vidic we
came we arrive at the same time we even
play with the reserve and we get sub
half time again
in the reserve
imagine me and nemanja vidic in the
shower
i remember i said oh my asians say you
know is homer i will maybe go back in
italy vidiq was like okay i will go to
small school also they they want me back
and stuff
so all of that my teammates were
laughing rio
when rooney went in the training i was
like sleeping and they were like
laughing when someone was you know
shoulder you they were laughing and i
remember one day port schools when i
make it when you respect me say you know
patrice
i think you were like a joker
i i even asked like the boss if he can
sell you back to monaco but for free
send you back for free yeah
and i look at them you know all those
things you know when i saw my teammate
laughing when i was not playing a game
he didn't put me down i was like i'm
going to show them what is the real
patrice because it's difficult when you
come to a club like you know
end of january because you know you miss
half of the season
so after i missed the world cup
my fellow
french teammates luisa and mikhail they
went to the world cup 2006. i was
filming
i back to monaco i was in the gym all
the summer
i was looking the french national team
reaching the final of world cup but they
lose against italy
so i was like okay i understand the
football in a in england now it's like
you have to be strong first then after
you can play with your feet so i get so
muscle everything i came back to the
pre-season we had a pre-season in south
africa
i was the man the the man of the
tournament and i remember mick phil and
the second coach he came and he shake my
hand said now you are united players
from that day even before the season
start
i know
i will make it and the rest is history
you played in a lot of teams
i sat here with ray ferdinand as well
i asked him a very similar question
what was it that made manchester united
achieve the success they achieved
this is so many things you know when you
say i can say like the wall getting the
discipline
uh the passion
the
i think is also the character
personality i think ferguson
he wanted to meet player in person to
see if he can feel their character their
personality
is they going to be ready to
to handle the pressure
pressure playing for manchester the
pressure is a gift
it's a privilege
like i want to add pressure like
i didn't want ferguson to say
you play a good game i want ferguson
like to give me the air trial it was a
little bit like it's it's really weird
but i didn't expect any compliment like
for me playing for
under sir alex ferguson and manchester
united i wasn't i never scared of anyone
i never scared
of sir alex ferguson but i was scared to
disappointing him
so it's about respect what make
manchester united was like
i have many coaches that say winning is
important but ferguson winning in united
is normal
like the goal is to win like four
trophy per season
i will i will tell you a story
when we won the champions league in 2008
exciting we went on the plane putting
the music loud you know dancing
ryan giggs look at me can can you know
can you put this i was like hey we just
win the champions league and the premier
league yeah but you know we need to
sleep we need to rest
okay that's that's weird
we land ferguson i remember we were on
the bus and he take the mic
he said congratulations
well done i'm proud of you to be in the
champion of europe
but uh next year
if you don't want to win it again
i will end many contracts of many player
of you if you don't i don't feel the
same passion and the same anger
now because he was the euro 2008 now go
and enjoy having uh and use the effect
the f word with your with your national
team
boom no parade no celebration with the
fan
i remember i went home and
i was with my back i drop it i was like
this is the feeling of winning the
champions league and the league
i was like wow
but the problem
you become a robot
so you're not even happy when you win
the league the years and years i was you
know when we celebrate and uh it was
fake
inside he was just pretending
of course it's a release it's an
achievement but because you just become
a machine a robot
winning that's the only things matter
and that's why he could he goes to play
for man united but also sacrifice
you know when i talk about sacrifice i'm
not shame about
you even have to sacrifice your own
family
that's what i did i gave you an example
you know
my first son lenny he was three years
old
and i came back home one day and he was
crying
i said why are you crying he said
because i hate manchester united
i say why he said because they they took
my dad away
and you know the united fan they have a
flag where they united
kids and wife in that order i never
laugh
in that flag a lot of people laugh and
ever because that's
that's the the that's what it caused me
to succeed at united was united united
that's why i had a really strong
relationship with ferguson because
he knew
i don't need manchester united i love
manchester united and i could like die
for this club and i still could die for
this club for the fan
and for any manager
so
to play for manchester united
it costs you
your life your normal life
you you're part of another family
it's interesting because when you were
younger you had a problem with authority
exactly ferguson is the ultimate
authority
i still
in different way i still you know
ferguson
sometimes he child on me i was stood up
facing like i was like
if you go far i don't know i don't
guarantee nothing will happen but
it's also i was i wanted to make sure
i didn't want to disobey in front of
people
this is really important because you
always question
you know
the coach if you answer back and that's
why i also say to kids when the manager
talk you should never answer back in the
in front of the people but
you can go after and that's what i was
doing with ferguson
so i tell you one game
we play against tottenham winning tune
in halftime playing the best game in my
life i promise you i was like wow on
fire came back in the dressing room in
some water people oh my god patrice
you're on fire everything
i said ferguson said when he sit and he
doesn't speak for
for three minutes or five like you you
mean like someone is in trouble i look
at him he look at me
you say patrice you okay
and me yeah yeah i'm okay boss yeah
are you tired
seriously i look around if he was like a
prank if he was some camera
even people were like what
i said no he said why you passed the
ball back to van der sar
i say because i i didn't have any
solution forward and that was the only
path i passed because i like to play
forward
if you do that again
i will you will come and watch the the
rest of the game next to me
and you use the many f words he said
this is the worst game you playing since
you played for manchester united that's
why i stood up i was like what's going
on
this is this is like this is it was like
you shouldn't if you pass the ball back
again i promise you you will never play
for
and justice
like i stand up
but i keep my mouth shut i was biting my
lips
even people they were in shock they were
scared like gigs everyone was like
what's going on
came back they're going off
we beat tottenham foreign and everything
after the game everyone oh my god don't
listen to him patrice you were on fire
yeah did my shower quickly
i remember then i couldn't wait to sleep
and to come back the next day
next day i come
happen who is it i opened the door oh
patrice how are you my son
say boss oh i am
what's happened yesterday
patrice you were the best player on the
beach but you know cristiano was started
doing some skill some player they were
like missing a chance to score you know
when you play for my united when you
score one goal you have to score second
when you score second you have to score
third goal you have to respect the
people they come to watching
i was like wait a minute boss
you were the best player my son
ali get out of my office
ffc i want
french fc
uh annie was like whistling singing and
laughing then i came out of the office
i was like actually
you know i could take the the fire he
wanted to send a message to the other
player the christiana
cristiano and many of the player
to keep focus and to respect tottenham
but he he picked the best player on the
pitch to send that message automatically
or the other player they were like
if he's killing the best player in the
pitch
we're better
but that's what i'm talking about
managing
that's fergie
you had a bust up with fergie in 2007
yeah
when he didn't play you oh yeah he
promised he'd play you then didn't play
oh yeah
is uh
this was a and even now and even i'm
going to see him uh
on saturday
i never ask him the real reason so it's
simple
i've
played every cup game effect game
i've been named the best left back in
the premier league it was like you know
competition with me and enzo but i i
play more game and
anyway
the final before the
day before the final he did the team now
he come we were walking with carlos
carriers
and it was unfortunately an article on
the
on the paper
and a big title
in the sun and it was like patrice evra
x drug dealer
uh gangster and a first page
wow you know what they did they went to
my where i grew up
they questioned many of my friends
and all of my friends they said yes yeah
you know we were fighting you know doing
this and
you know and they said but patrice is an
example for us because he made it
so that pepper is that telling oh i was
a gangster and everything so it was a
front page
and the day before the game ferguson we
were walking going to train and he said
ah
ah we need to talk you know
say what's the matter boss you say
you know the the glazer the owner they
call me and uh
you know for the club for the image of
the club you know next gangster and
stuff is
you know it's no good i think i won't
play you tomorrow
i was like
but bossy no i'm joking and he was kind
of like too curious oh i got him you
know he was scared no no don't worry
we train
the first level on the team
everything perfect
the the day of the game in the morning i
like to put music i remember in the
ferguson allowed you also to order your
breakfast in your room you don't need to
go downstairs and
dancing
okay i think it's the room service open
the door so alex ferguson he said
son
uh
i'm gonna put you in the bench
ends are gonna start
but you know what i know you're going to
win the game for us you know it's really
warm wembley you're going to come in i
need some speed sometimes you're going
to win the game i know you disappointed
i said i am very disappointed
he said i know i know son but trust me
and hit up he left so i remember
after 10 minutes he asked me to warm up
we weren't playing well
i warm up for 80 minutes it was even
like the smoking like i was like first
of all i was really angry and i was like
running like crazy mad because i needed
like you know
they all this frustration has to come
out we lost one nil against chelsea
i remember we went to take all the medal
i take it i'd throw it on the grass
ferguson
check tried to shake my hand i didn't
shake his hand so first first time in my
life i didn't respect him
uh my agent was there why you don't play
i said go to us you're a manager people
from manchester are you injury patrice
no
go to us to your manager i say to my
agent i need to go i don't want to play
for my united anymore find me a club no
patrice i need to go i don't want to
play for my united anymore
it was the party everyone was like with
the family and stuff i wasn't smiling
and uh
three days later ferguson called me and
they say
actually i'm sorry i should have played
you uh
i hope you're not too upset and uh and
because he told me that
i automatically forgive him but i still
don't know
the reasons especially what's happening
in the favor and the joke
and i never ask him the reason
but yeah i was uh that's that's it
that's what i was i don't want to play
for united anymore are you going to ask
him
no because i'm someone
you know i know you see a lot of my
interview and my stuff and even watch my
videos so maybe
he's going to tell me one day but i
don't ask i don't ask people
i just like to people they are free if
they want to say something about
something just tell me i don't like to
ask people does it bother you
uh when i talk about it
just think like yeah
but not really because at the end the
rest of my career for united and the
love i've got for this man you know his
history so
no but it's just like again my past
maybe my past cost me you know
my starting 11 but
forgiveness
the topic of forgiveness
um
suarez
suarez um
in an altercation on the pitch he called
you negrito i was watching that game
which is a um offensive word
for um a black person
that incident was a um
was a bit of a media circus wasn't it
yeah
but i will never expect that because
uh
so like you say and
he called me enough unfortunately for
him i speak uh spanish and
i say
what did you say and he said again the n
word and
he said anyway i don't speak with uh
any n
the n word
so i remember in that time i was like
this is this is when i was like also
proud of myself because i was talking to
myself
should i punch him
but patrice this is a liverpool
manchester
all the kids are watching this game or
it's people won't understand so
i promise you this i had an amazing
first half the second half i was just
like it was a process talking to my
don't do it you know when you have like
a the devil and an angel don't do it do
it don't do it do it all the game i
wasn't in the game and i played okay it
was fine we drew and after the game i
just sat and ferguson saw me and he was
like patrice uh what's the matter
you know you had a good game what's the
matter i said no
david de gea say suarez call him a
a negrito
i was like patrice let's go
take me we went to the raw for the
referee
we tell him he take note but by the way
even in the
on the pitch i said to the referee did
you hear what he just said he called me
with the n word come on patrice he
called me with the n word play play play
we're going to deal with that letter
because i forget to always mention that
in his long time and every interview i
never say that
and that referee we're going to deal
with that later really he called you
that yes he did
okay
so we went to the official we tell he
said yeah patrice told me about that so
he was aware so ferguson like kill him
so you were aware and why you didn't
send him off
yeah okay we're gonna deal with that and
you know to the english federation so
the next day
boom
front page
uh suarez you know
racially abused but you server
well i didn't expect that so
i don't know how possible i start to
become a liar
i start to become
people in jail in liverpool send many
letters
of they're going to kill me when they're
going to come out of jail
people start following me with my car
i had for 3 months 24 hours like
security but can i be honest with you
my brothers and my family they were like
scared but i was like guys we don't need
that because i'm from the streets so
come on we don't need protection but the
freight we're real that's why my united
say patrice
even if you don't need that we need so
for for three months like 24 hours and
everything so
unbelievable
but the worst part is when we watch a
game
with all the player and ferguson and we
saw the liverpool player came out with
that shirt and we support this why and
the worst part he was like he get banned
so it's not like they do it when
before he get the ban he get banned
because after he lie he said you know in
my country we use the word like i know
they use nero but no negrito negrito is
the n word nero is the color
and even i always say to people you
don't have to call me by my caller
my mom gave me a name
i don't need to be anywhere so with the
camera they could see with his lips like
he said the n word
and they support him and he was kevin
douglas i remember i hate so much kevin
douglas to let this happen that day and
the karma he gets sacked after one month
after that game so
i did a a tv show with uh jimmy garger
and uh
i promised you hi jamie like you know
[Music]
we we start talking and he say patrice i
just would like to apologize about
what's happening nine years ago
what we have done is wrong i was in
shock seriously i didn't expect that i
was like wow okay
he say we didn't know you know the club
tell us to do that and
and after that i received like a letter
from the owner of liverpool
uh emails saying like we most we saw you
more than welcome here and everything
you can feel home i will never feel home
when i go to liverpool thank you for
that but it was so nice and i know many
of my friends they were like patrice uh
um you should uh you should forgive them
i say guys it's never it's never too
late and i don't have any hate and i
keep saying i can't call luis suarez a
racist because i don't know him close
enough to call him that way but in that
day he used some racist word and he get
even worse for him
when about the handshake
that's when i was like okay it's a
disgrace
because even when i called my mom and my
mom said the way indicate patrice you
should forgive
and i remember that game was one of the
most
like topic was the handshake
it wasn't even liverpool
that's when i see like he was bigger
than
that that things was bigger than the
game
and when i put and he did and i was like
you put your hand out he didn't yeah
yeah and i was like i'm going to kill
him now i remember that game i even take
a real affair you know you can see
because i wanted to to catch suarez but
he jumped so i take like real fad you
know and he's that picture when rio fed
you know you look like he's broken his
neck because i wasn't wanted to play the
game i just wanted to kill him
and i have one story also
after all those episodes one day i was
walking in the manchester in dean's gate
and uh
my brother said oh he's lucious over
there i was with you two of my brother
i looked at him
i was like that's it this is the moment
and he walked
and behind him i saw his kid and his
wife
and we and i turned my back
i was like if you do something to him
you can't do this in front of his family
so
i don't regret it because i think he
will end the bad and i didn't do nothing
that day
i saw him when we play against uh
barcelona with juventus in the final i
was talking with neymar he passed he got
me shake my hand say you're okay i say
i'm okay you're okay
so no beef but we definitely know going
to go in holiday
in our life but
yeah have you forgiven him
yeah but because like i say
that's when now we
i want to talk a little bit about the
racism and uh like i said to people is
about education no one born as a racist
person and you know when you
when the football now they ban people
when they
have those racist comments or
i don't think this is the solution
because if you burn someone you him i
know he's really sensitive but you put
him in a box you don't resolve the
matter
and even that person will even become
more racist and feeling more rejected
but where he come from i've got friend
they're not ashamed to tell me patrice
i've got black friend and everything but
my daughter or my my uh son will never
be with a black belt because my dad or
my granddad will never accept it
so that's why i understand you know
racism you need to fight with your own
parents
it's nothing to do it's about religion
when it was the paris attack
everyone start to blaming the muslim
people islam
i did a post i was on the plane
i say you know what and by the way
i grew up as a catholic but
if you ask me what is your best religion
right now is to be the best human being
i can i'm not a catholic i'm not a
muslim but i can pray with jewish people
with muslim people
buddha everything because i respect
every religion but now the religion my
religion is to be the best human being i
can
then i did that post when i say i think
it's not time to
to spread your anger your you know is we
need to pray for the people we lost
and by the way i read the quran islam is
such a beautiful religion it's about
love and everything so
i really and it came from my heart
and i feel like i had to do it
my dad called me
what you doing you know you don't know
them they are terrorists and everything
i said that this is your opinion but
it's not mine
he put the phone down we didn't speak
for two weeks
he called me after two weeks he said i'm
sorry
say wow you're a man now you stood to
your own opinion
i said yes dad and i won't change it
like you can't because one person do
something then all the people are the
same
so that's why i like to give this
example because sometimes you have to
stand up against your you know your own
your own father even if you scare him
because those people
the racist doesn't come like because
they just become racist it's because
they've been taught
so if we want to change something is
about the education
you know and
i have enough people pretending
they want to fight against racism
and i will talk about massive like
football industry
i give the example of the
that stupid super league
super league a project that project
didn't even start
we shut down that project in 24 hours
i remember i watched on tv my ex
teammate upon the shooting the fun
fighting burning things like i was like
wow i was watching i was like oh my god
they are so unique determinate
the president of the the fifa tokyo they
were five feet oh they are snake those
owners and stuff like wow we should
but i was like but why we don't have the
same determination
when we talk about racism especially in
football
players getting abused
every single game
but we don't start so don't pretend
you want to do it when you don't but the
real reason and me i'm straight and
maybe i'm irritated certain person
that typically you were touching their
pocket
races
it's not about money everyone like you
don't care
play on
you know like even social media
i'm someone i am on social media i don't
want any help from instagram uh from
facebook forever because you can delete
your comment you can like block people
everything and anyway when i have rest
is common i will do a nice video when
i'm eating a banana and things because
it really like when i was 70 years old
people were throwing real banana in my
face when i was playing so it's not like
someone behind his computer can affect
me but this is patrice
other people they're going to read
comment about them they're going to even
suicide you know when we're talking
about the mental health
so you have to explain me one thing
one is about the kovid 90
you get the flags right away
but when is about the races like
sometimes you feel like the social media
they just let the the race they spread
the races on on the and on their own
platform
so stop pretending if you want to do
something let's do it but i know
until you know money is not involved
things will difficult to be changed yeah
kick the races they asked me to put the
shirts many time i go to the woman i
didn't put that shirt because i don't
it's fake they they ask me like to say
no to the races in front of the camera
many players respect no touristy
but the player they don't they don't
even care because they just
they tell them to say that
come
teach to people racism saying those
words now you i say silence is a crime
because people lose their life because
of that you know
you said your religion was to live a
good life no to be the best human being
be your best human being you can um how
do you define that now
uh
what does that mean
it mean to uh
to be kind
to people to be kind to the universe
uh to make the world a better place
to help people
to to like i'll be honest with you now
and i say that not to make myself
looking good when i do a video and i see
a comment someone say oh patrice
my dad passed away i watch one of your
video and i smile
thank you
this is more important for me than win
the championship or the premier league
because this touched my heart
you know like i said i play football
yeah
but might be also one of my biggest
achievements and i don't want to talk
about it to spread it but it's when i
open my two shelter in senegal more than
400 kids
and i remember the day
when i went there and they were singing
for me
because i gave them food and you know
school and everything
that's when i'm like
ah now i know why i'm on earth
not just to kick a ball around
that's it that's why i say people they
i'm like an iceberg you know i like to
use that
that example because i think people
didn't see
the real portrays and you know many
managers they named me captain of the
you know i remember the first time like
ferguson said you're going to be the
captain and rio was still playing geeks
and wayne rooney a lot of people i was
like the french guys from the street
he's the captain of the biggest club you
know in the world
but because they know that culture of
sharing leadership
not being selfish all of that this is me
and
one things i changed
because of my woman is
i'm taking care of myself now i also
want to be happy because before
if the world is happy if you are happy
this make me happy
but now patrice also sometimes he take
his time like i had like
can you believe in the last two years i
have just one holiday
to tell you like even now i'm retired
but i'm more busy than when i used to
play but
for the first time i turned my phone off
for a week
it was just amazing
because i don't allowed to do that
because i've got things to do i got
people to take care for us for the first
time i take care of myself
it was just magic like my woman just
wanted to lock me down in that island
and didn't want me to coming back and i
won't be able to do actually this
podcast today so
so we did it i come back to reality but
yeah this is tell you like i just
i
it's not just want to be good i just
want to be myself and you know i never
i had one one problem is like i still
like to fight
so this is like from from where i grew
up
so
sometimes my woman teach me like don't
use your fist you know again
on my book when i kick that fan
and people compare me to eric cantona
but it wasn't my you know my goal
in marseille but it's because this guy
is like stop you know
like talking like a monkey and anyway
when we go back we're gonna cut the
throat off your kids and i am a human
being and that's why people forget
sometimes footballer player they think
we are like robot but no we are we got
feeling when he did that he came down so
i i kick him i get
eight months back
i think atk or fine i don't remember
so
i'm not perfect and i don't want to be
perfect i want to be me
some people i am an example for them
but i don't want it's not like i want to
be an example for anyone i just want to
be me if i inspire people
then perfect
you are an iceberg
you're definitely an iceberg that's for
sure
and this book definitely reveals that
the rest of the iceberg that doesn't
sit above the water
and
as someone as i said that's watched john
screen for many many decades and has
seen you more recently online and as a
pundit on tv i would never have guessed
their sort of complexity and backstory
that um
that you have and your sort of
you know interesting word to use but
your
your vulnerability let's say in sharing
all of that i think will do more good
than you'll ever realize because it it
opens the door for other people to share
and as we said it creates a safe space
for men young men men that come from
where you come from men like me to also
share and in sharing we liberate
ourselves
that tends to be what happens and then
we we are we have permission to live a
more free life because because of that
so i want to thank you for that i think
that's uh
one of the most um amazing things you
can do and you've done that with this
book and um on behalf of everybody that
has the chance of reading it and i hope
everybody does go and read it
um thank you
no thanks to you to having me and
to also some emotion you know you you
bring out some emotion i didn't know one
and i did many interview when i'm doing
my booktube and question like you asked
me today and
it's really i trust you the way i've
been honest and no thank to you because
i'm already feeling better
and that's why i hope like every people
and every kids they have the chance to
to read my book and you know if they are
like those issue to to come out
it's not easy you know it's easy for me
to tell them please come out but
trust someone trust someone and trust me
you it's a massive like things i've got
in my chest for so many years
and
for me like i said to my mom traveling
and she was just devastated and
sometimes she still send me some voice
notes she's crying because she could
still don't understand so don't keep it
don't keep it tell it to your parents
tell it to your brothers or your sister
i've got 24 brothers and sisters
and i didn't even tell that to any one
of them
so
be yourself
enjoy your life leave the present
and be good to the universe
that's a beautiful ending i have
just one more question for you this is a
question this is a new tradition we've
started patrice where the previous guest
on this podcast leaves a question for
the next guest
so the previous guest left a question
for you and you're going to leave a
question for the next guest as well
and i'm going to find out what that
question is because i've not actually
read it yet okay here we go
name three people
dead or alive
that you would have dinner with tonight
if you could
my mom
my woman
and you
oh that's a tremendous honor
why me
because
because the way you
many things came out and
and you're an interesting person and i
feel energy and i feel your soul and
you're a good soul and i can see
you're doing all of this because you
want to make the world a better place
and you know when you surrendered around
people like you you just improved
and that's what i wanted you know
sometimes i'm like don't surrender about
negative people help them also to
understand why they are negative
but your your energy you're really
curious i can feel it you're going deep
you want to understand the reason why
because it's easy to to dig the book i
do but i wanted someone was able to ask
me the reason
why
and that's what i you know i can have a
conversation and we can have a dinner
and we're going to talk about a lot of
things and i really about the toxic you
know masculinity yeah so that's why i
thank you okay well we're going to
organize that dinner so you know we'll
we'll figure it out um for sure because
i feel the same way as i'm still kind of
early on that journey of understanding
my ego and toxic masculinity and how it
stands in my way
the more men that i can speak to like
yourself and i've been on that journey
and started to learn lessons the better
it will be for myself selfishly but
hopefully that's uh you know and i think
you know the the good i think we've just
done talking about that today and it's
funny because i i know some of the
people that listen to this and where
they listen to it because they tag me
yeah and they are men that are driving
eight hours on a monday morning up and
down the country in big vans they are
builders on building sites that want to
be entrepreneurs and just again as we've
done on this podcast creating that safe
space where we can talk about feelings
and crying and your emotions and
communicate communicating what's going
on in your life oh it's the most
important service i think we can do to
men um so i hope we can carry on that
conversation and i'm going to be
pestering your pa to organize this
dinner
man i'm going to pass you the book to
write a question for my next guest but
thank you so much it's been an absolute
honour honestly it's been an absolute
honor and you're
you're even more of a role model to me
than you have been for the last 20 years
and that's been that's hard to beat so
thank you thank you
[Music]
you